I didn't bring you here just a sip some
tea I wanted to spill some tea so I
thought of a game I like to call it sip
it and spill and it's basically a very
sophisticated version of never have I
ever so I'm trying to keep something
very American and trashy classy but for
example sip it and spill it if you've
ever loved your self in a bathroom with
a glass of wine because you have
children and you just want a minute to
yourself see then I would take this bad
boy and I'd drink a fine how you drink
that way if you've ever rolled Easter
eggs while wearing a bonnet and dress oh
my friend said put on our dress and
let's roll Easter Egg down the hill so
we don't this makes me my favorite
person at the table I know once again
okay wait here
zip it and spill it if you've ever
snowed Brad Pitt snob means kissed right
are you about to I show you t well I'm
just bit mean it would just go story
somebody had to as a paid job because we
were on a set what a baby the patient
yes can see there are worse ways to earn
a living
so I was not complaining but yeah he cut
his teeth with me
yes he made him a good smoger I'll call
it that sounds not cool I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this